these floor designs are so intricate
it's hard to believe that each component
is an individually cut piece of marble
granite or other natural stone whether
the design covers an entire floor or is
a single decorative insert the starting
point is a stone slab it's massive
but extremely thin so it's actually
quite fragile workers use a pneumatic
suction hoist to position the slab onto
a cutting machine table it cuts with the
jet of water the water contains
particles of garnet an extremely hard
gemstone the jet cuts by eroding the
stone rather than by sheer force which
would crack it
workers rinse away the stone grit and
abrasive residue once the cutting is
finished they use suction cups to remove
the cut pieces one at a time some will
go into the floor as is while others go
onto a smaller water jet machine which
cuts them into intricate shapes workers
extract these smaller pieces with
tweezers every component of the design
has a number workers label the back of
the corresponding piece accordingly then
they print out a life-size version of
the number design on a sheet of durable
polyester film
then they lay one piece at a time front
side down onto the template like a
puzzle the design slowly reveals itself
once the design is fully laid out they
tack the pieces together with glue this
keeps them from shifting or separating
they lay fiberglass mesh over the entire
assembly then they prepare an epoxy
resin specially formulated for stone
setting and spread it evenly over the
mesh they let it set overnight and the
next day they sanded flat the cut stone
design is now bonded together in a solid
unit now they can safely flip it face-up
the final step is to fill the joints
with epoxy grout then wash off any
excess with a wet sponge this is just
one of several components of a large
elaborate design workers assemble them
together to do a quality control check
then they take the design apart and
package each component separately for
shipping stone must always ship upright
on its side because it can crack when
transported horizontally however the cut
stone floor will be sturdy enough to
walk on once it's properly installed
just be careful not to bump into
anything while you're admiring the art
beneath your feet